[Musik]
vor einigen Tagen verbreiteten sich über
die asozialen Medien obskure
Desinformationen dass im Zusammenhang
mit dem Krieg in Israel chinesische
Kriegsschiffe vor der Küste des Landes
liegen würden um in den dortigen
Konflikt einzugreifen nun das ist
natürlich totaler Quatsch dass manche
Menschen selbst bei solch
offensichtlichen Fake News herhörig
werden kommt aber nicht von ungefähr
seit einigen Jahren erklärt die große
Mehrheit der internationalen Analysten
nämlich dass die Vorherrschaft der USA
in der Welt vorbei sei das Szenario das
aus dem Fall der Berliner Mauer und dem
Ende der Sowjetunion resultierte und
dass eine unipolare Welt unter der
Führung von ankel Sam nährte ist für
viele nicht mehr zeitgemäß und warum nun
aus einem ganz einfachen Grund wegen des
Aufstieg eines Landes das in USA die
Stirn bietet
China kein Wunder schließlich reden wir
über ein Land das zur größten Industrie
macht und zur zweitgrößten
Volkswirtschaft der Welt aufgestiegen
ist ist aber es handelt sich nicht nur
um eine Frage der Wirtschaft China ist
auch eine militärische Großmacht und
zwar in zunehmendem Maße in diesem
Zusammenhang verfügt China bereits über
die zweit stärksten Streitkräfte der
Welt abgesehen von seinen Atomwaffen es
liegt auf der Hand dass bei einer
solchen industriellen wirtschaftlichen
und militärischen Macht das Ende der
unipolaren Welt bereits eine Tatsache
ist natürlich ist es nicht einfach mit
den USA Schritt zu halten und wohl China
beeindruckende Anstrengung unternommen
hat weisen viele Analysten bereits auf
Ermüdungserscheinungen beim chinesischen
Drachen hin vor allem weil ein großes
und modernes Militär in erster Linie
eines braucht viel Geld und deshalb
stellen wir heute hier auf visualpolitik
ein paar kritische Fragen wie sieht
überhaupt die Lage in China aus ist es
möglich dass die anhaltenden Probleme
des asiatischen riesen auch sein
militärisches Engagement verlangsamen
inwi weit verstärken sich diese
Tendenzen oder wird Peking doch wieder
erstärken wusstet ihr eigentlich dass
China bereits über die größte
seestreitkraft der Welt verfügt und was
könnte das bedeuten für die USA und die
Welt heute werden wir all die diese
spannenden Fragen natürlich beantworten
und zwar gleich nach der knackigen
werbbotschaft unseres Sponsors blinkist
denn die Berliner Firma blinkist hat mit
ihrem Beitrag nicht nur das heutige
Video möglich gemacht nein wir nutzen
Ihre App auch selbst um täglich unseren
eigenen Wissenshorizont zu erweitern
vielleicht fragt ihr euch ja manchmal
wie wir es schaffen so viel Wissen aus
verschiedenen Bereichen miteinander in
unseren Videos zu verknüpfen nun der
Schlüssel dazu ist vor allem lesen lesen
und manchmal auch hören Artikel Analysen
Videos Podcasts und vor allem Bücher mit
Grundlagenwissen das notwendig ist um
diese Information zu einem Gesamtbild
verknüpfen zu können aber was wenn man
gar nicht die Zeit dazu hat so viele
verschiedene Bücher zu lesen nun genau
dann ist man bei blinkist richtig denn
es verschafft einem nicht nur mehr Zeit
sondern motiviert auch noch durch die
unterhaltsame Aufmachung blink ist
bringt das Wichtigste aus mehr als 5000
Sachbüchern und Podcasts auf dein Handy
und dann erlebst du einen ungeahnten
wissensboost anstatt Stunden in die
Lektüre eines Buches zu stecken und es
dann vielleicht gar nicht zu Ende zu
lesen ziehst du dir in ull kom nichts
die immer sehr angenehm und locker
geschriebene blinkest Version rein man
merkt dass da echte Profis und Talente
am Werk sind stell dir vor wir würden
ein wertvolles aber langes Buch in ein
knackiges und leicht verdauliches
visualpolitik Video Gießen nun genau das
macht blinkest ein Beispiel sind auch
Bücher von Autoren mit denen man
vielleicht nicht immer einer Meinung ist
womit aber kann man sein Horizont besser
erweitern als mit Information die eben
nicht aus der eigenen buabble stammen
mir ist z.B das Buch kein Kapitalismus
ist auch keine Lösung der ehemaligen TAS
Autorin Ulrike Hermann aufgefallen auch
hier habe ich mir gesagt okay Tat ist
nicht gerade mein Leib und magenblatt
Rezensenten auf Amazon haben das Buch
auch dafür kritisiert langatmig zu sein
muss ich mir das also wirklich antun
andererseits hat mich schon interessiert
was da drin steht tja und dank der
fesselnd geschriebenen blinkistfassung
konnte ich innerhalb von nur 25 Minuten
herausfinden dass dieses Werk zumindest
in der blinkist Version mein Horizont
durchaus bereichern konnte solides
Wissen dass ich ohne blinkist sicher
verpasst hätte kurz gesagt diese App
wird mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit auch
dein Leben bereichern egal für welches
Thema du dich gerade interessierst die
Auswahl und das Spektrum sind wahrlich
riesig von Finanzen über Wissenschaft
Politik Karriere bis zu den klassischen
Ratgeberthemen um sein Leben zu
optimieren aber man kann mit blinkist
nicht nur sich selbst sondern auch seine
Lieben bereichern es hat nämlich vor
kurzem eine ganz neue Funktion namens
blinkist spaces eingeführt damit kannst
du deine lieblings blinkist mit deinen
Freunden und Kollegen teilen und
diskutieren wie in einem Buchclub das
coole daran ist dass du auch blinkist
basic User in deinen space einladen
kannst und diese dort dann alle Titel
lesen und hören können auch wenn sie
normalerweise nur für Premium Mitglieder
zugänglich wären und das ist noch nicht
alles visualpitik Zuschauer bekommen
über den Link in der Beschreibung nicht
nur zwei Mitgliedschaften zum Preis von
einer sondern obenrein noch 60% Rabatt
also zögere nicht besorg dir jetzt
gleich die kostenlose 7 Tage Testversion
über den Link unter diesem Video und
fang dann gleich damit an deinen
Wissenschatz zu bereichern und wenn du
das erledigt hast können wir sofort zur
Beantwortung unserer spannenden Fragen
schreiten
aufgepasst Jing der wirtschaftliche
Abturner Jahrzehnte lang hat China allen
Indikatoren und Vorhersagen getrotzt und
sich zur größten Autokratie und zu einem
recht erfolgreichen autoritären Regime
entwickelt erst dachte man dass die
wirtschaftliche Entwicklung mehr
Offenheit und ein höheres Maß an
Freiheit mit sich bringen würde doch
inzwischen hat sich gezeigt dass diese
These nicht zutrifft seit den 1970er
Jahren gelang es China mit dengkscha
Pings Wirtschaftsreformen und dank
seiner reichhaltigen Demographie und
Wasserressourcen 800 Millionen Menschen
aus der Armut zu befreien bis zum Ende
der Amtszeit huinaos im Jahr 2012
schaffte China es sogar jährlich um etwa
10% zu
[Musik]
wachsen tja seit nämlich SH Ping
Präsident ist haben einige der Maßnahmen
die die Volksrepublik China auf das
weltpodium gebracht haben einen großen
Rückschlag erlitten shiinping hat viele
autoritäre und interventionistischere
Maßnahmen durchgesetzt er hat den
staatlichen Überwachungsapparat Gestell
stärkt und den staatlichen Unternehmen
Vorrang eingeräumt unter anderem inem er
viele zombistestaatsunternehmen mit
großen Kapitalmengen ausgestattet hat
hinzu kommt dass schießchina nicht mehr
die Vorteile seiner Vorgänger genießt
die Lohnkosten sind gestiegen der
Immobilienmarkt ist gesättigt das Land
importiert immer mehr Energie und Chinas
Bevölkerung altert und schrumpft
Schätzungen zurfolge werden bis 2050 700
Millionen Erwerbstätige für 500
Millionen Rentner aufkommen müssen das
sind 300 Millionen mehr als
heute
daher ist es nicht überraschend dass
China nicht mehr das Wachstum aufweist
das es vor dem Amtsantritt shiinpings
[Musik]
hatte in diesem Zusammenhang ist das
chinesische Wirtschaftswachstum seit der
Krise 2008 immer weiter zurückgegangen
shei ist es nicht gelungen diesen Trend
zu bremsen und das obwohl er mit
riesigen öffentlichen ausgabenpaketen
versucht hat dies zu erreichen aber es
geht nicht nur darum die chinesische
Wirtschaft steht vor vielen weiteren
gewaltigen Problemen und wenn wir über
über die Probleme Chinas sprechen müssen
wir auch folgendes berücksichtigen
Chinas Schuldenquote steigt aufgrund des
kreditboms auf den Rekordwert von
279,7% des BIP hinzu kommt die
Schließung von 4,4 Millionen Unternehmen
die durch die verrückte Null covidpitik
zur Aufgabe gezwungen worden es stimmt
zwar dass die Arbeitslosigkeit von 5,3
leicht auf 5,2% gesunken ist aber die
Realität sieht so aus dass die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit im Juni dieses
Jahres bei über 21% lag es ist leider
war dass die Wirtschaftsprognosen für
China im allgemeinen im Vergleich zu
früheren Perioden nach unten korrigiert
[Musik]
werden Goldman Sax hatte vorausgesagt
dass die chinesische Wirtschaft die
amerikanische im Jahr 2026 überholen und
ihr BIP bis 2050 doppelt so hoch sein
würde wie das von Unkel Sam aber all
diese Prognosen mussten im letzten Jahr
gnadenlos revidiert werden damals wurde
schon vorher gesagt dass China die USA
bis 2035 überholen und ihr BIP höchstens
um 15 Prozent übertreffen würde aber
wahrscheinlich sind sie heute noch
weniger optimistisch deswegen bezweifeln
immer mehr Analysten dass China die USA
überhaupt einholen wird und wohl gemerkt
dabei geht es nur um das BP in absoluten
Zahlen und ohne irgendwas anderes zu
berücksichtigen ihr dürft nicht glauben
dass es sich dabei um chinabäching oder
ähnliches handelt ganz im Gegenteil bei
visualpolitik haben wir die großen
Fortschritte dieses Landes gefeiert und
darüber berichtet china hat in den
letzten 40 Jahren im Allgemeinen einen
sehr positiven Beitrag für die Welt
geleistet trotzdem sagen wir schon seit
einigen Jahren dass die Dinge sowohl
wirtschaftlich als auch politisch
schlechter werden oder zumindest nicht
mehr gut laufen genau das haben wir
bereits vor einigen Jahren vorausgesagt
und es tritt jetzt eben ein viele von
euch werden vielleicht denken dass in
diesem Zusammenhang die Tatsache dass
der asiatische Riese die USA
wirtschaftlich nicht überholen wird eine
gute Nachricht ist aber viele der
Analysten die diese Vorhersage machen
sind auch der Meinung dass es sich um
eine ernsthafte Gefahr handelt und wieso
eigentlich sollte nicht das Gegenteil
der Fall sein nun passt jetzt mal gut
auf
[Musik]
die mächtige chinesische
Marine ich bin sicher viele von euch
haben in den letzten Jahren gehört dass
der Aufstieg Chinas die USA in ernste
Schwierigkeiten bringen könnte einige
angesehene Analysten wie z.B Graham
Allison von der Harvard University haben
sogar behauptet dass der Aufstieg Chinas
undter daraus resultierende Niedergang
der USA unweigerlich zu einem Krieg
führen würde angesichts der aktuellen
Situation in China und der immer
schlechteren Wachstumsprognosen beginnen
viele Analysten allerdings bereits isens
Theorie zu verwerfen inzwischen haben
diese Analysten begonnen eine andere
Theorie zu vertreten demnach erreicht
China seinen Höhepunkt der aber immer
noch weit unter dem der USA liegt und
sobald Peking diesen Punkt erreicht hat
wird der Abstieg beginnen tja und jetzt
haltet euch fest ihrer Meinung nach ist
dieses Szenario das wirklich
besorgniserregende und zwar für die USA
und den Rest der Welt aber warum ist das
so nun aus einem einfachen Grund so wie
es kein gefährlicheres Tier gibt als
eines das verwundet ist gibt es auch
kein gefährlicheres Land als eines das
sich im Niedergang befindet wir haben es
im fallalle Russlands erlebt wenn Sie
versuchen ihren Niedergang zu verhindern
greifen sie oft zu Gewalt und wisst ihr
was China in all den Jahren getan hat
nun seht's euch
an in folgedessen hat das Land sein
Verteidigungshaushalt erhöht und zwar um
sage und schreibe 9% pro Jahr seit die
in den 1990ern angekündigte
Modernisierung der Streitkräfte
gestartet wurde auf diese Weise bläst
China seinen Militärhaushalt bis 2023
auf 224 Milliarden Dollar auf und damit
ist er der zweitgrößte der Welt mit all
diesem Geld hat China seine
militärischen Fähigkeiten schrittweise
modernisiert so verfügt es heute über
1700 Kampfflugzeuge darunter J11 und
su30 die mit der amerikanischen F16 und
F18 vergleichbar sind und natürlich
verfügt China so heute über die größte
Luftwaffe Asiens aber könnt ihr erraten
in welchen Zweig der Streitkräfte sie am
meisten investiert haben 3 2 1 ihr
habt's erraten die
Marine Chinas Marin Modernisierung
begann in den 1990er Jahren und hat dazu
geführt dass die chinesische Marine mit
351 Schiffen im Jahr 2022 die größte der
Welt ist zumindest was die Anzahl der
Schiffe angeht damit liegt sie aber
sogar noch vor der US Navy die im selben
Jahr 294 Schiffe hatte außer hat China
nicht nur mehr Schiffe sondern auch
deren Ausstattung hat sich seit den
1990er Jahren erheblich verbessert unter
anderem durch die Einführung von
ballistischen Raketen und
antischiffsmarschflugkörpern sowie
andereer Ausrüstung und nicht nur das
China hat auch eine große Flotte von
U-Booten Zerstörern und Kreuzern darüber
hinaus hat es sich sogar als
zweitstärkste macht etabliert wenn es um
die meisten Flugzeugträger geht 2012 und
2019 stellte es seine ersten beiden
Flugzeugträger vor und 2022 sein dritten
die Fujian ein Schiff das bereits über
Katapulte und eine elektromagn
Startvorrichtung für Jets
verfügt aber glaubt ihr dass China mit
dieser großen Flotte die US Navy
besiegen kann nun im Moment scheint dies
nicht der Fall zu sein es stimmt zwar
dass China über mehr Schiffe verfügt und
in diesem Zusammenhang wird sogar
erwartet dass die chinesische Marine bis
2030 um 50% größer sein wird als die der
USA aber die Realität sieht nun mal so
aus dass ankel Sam zwar weniger Schiffe
hat diese aber größer und
leistungsfähiger
[Musik]
sind im Vergleich zu den chinesischen
Flugzeugträgern sind die amerikanischen
z.B viel größer haben einen Atomantrieb
der ihnen mehr Autonomie verleiht und
können mehr Flugzeuge starten und
betreiben in manchen Fällen sogar mehr
als 60 vergesst bitte auch nicht dass
die USA über mehr militärisch wichtige
Schiffe wie Flugzeugträger Kreuzer und
Zerstörer verfügen was ihnen in einem
Kriegsszenario einen klaren Vorteil
verschaffen würde aber unabhängig davon
ob China sich wirklich auf den Höhepunkt
seiner Macht vorbereitet oder nicht ist
klar dass Peking eine beeindruckende
militärische und vor allem maritime
macht geworden ist daran gibt es keinen
Zweifel allerdings es ist überhaupt kein
Zufall dass so viele Ressourcen
ausgerechnet in die Marine geflossen
sind und deswegen werden wir den Grund
dafür jetzt mal genau unter die Lupe
nehmen das Spiel mit dem
Risiko viele haben versucht
herauszufinden wie China Strategie
aussehen würde um eine Supermacht zu
werden die es mit den USA aufnehmen kann
und die meisten sind zu dem Schluss
gekommen dass sich alles um eine Region
drehen wird die Vorherrschaft im
Südchinesischen Meer sollte China die
totale Kontrolle über diese Region
erlangen deutet alles darauf hin dass
wir bereits vor einer Supermacht auf dem
Niveau von ankel Sam sprechen könnten
man muss nämlich wissen dass es in
diesem mehr nachgewiesen Reserven von 11
Milliarden Barrel Öl gibt und noch mehr
erbgas aber wirklich wichtig ist an
diesem Meer der enorme geostrategische
Vorteil den es demjenigen verschaffen
würde dem es kingt ist vollständig zu
beherrschen und in diesem Fall ist der
größte Anwärter dafür
China die enorme Aufrüstung der
chinesischen Marine erklärt sich daher
aus dem Bestreben Pekings eine Weltmacht
zu werden die in der Lage ist die
internationale Ordnung zu formen china
möchte aber auch seine maritimen
Handelsrouten sichern da 80% der
chinesischen Handelsgeschäfte entlang
dieser Route abgewickelt werden aus
diesem Grund hat China nicht gezögert
sich über das Völkerrecht hinweg zuen
und die berühmte neun Strichlinie
einzurichten damit will Peking das
Risiko einer Unterbrechung der
Versorgung mit strategischen götern wie
z.B ölverringern wie ihr euch vielleicht
erinnert umreist die neu strichlinien
jenes Gebiet das China für sich
beansprucht obwohl es in die
Wirtschaftszonen von Nachbaren wie den
Philippinen Vietnam Malaysia und Brunei
eingreift innerhalb dieser von China
beanspruchten Linie befinden sich Inseln
die auch von seinen Nachbaren
beansprucht werden wie z.B die spreadle
oder die paracellinsel die China
gewaltsam erobert militarisiert und
künstlich erweitert
[Musik]
hat der Hauptgrund oder zumindest der
über den am meisten gesprochen wird ist
allerdings nicht diese sondern Chinas
Absicht in naher Zukunft auf der Insel
Formosa also Taiwan
einzufallen China strebt bis 2027 eine
bewaffnete Vereinigung mit Taiwan an so
ein führender Akademiker Taiwans
Außenminister wart vor einem Konflikt
mit China im Jahr
2027 dies ist sicherlich der größte
spspkt zwischen den USA und China unter
anderem aus dem Grund weil Taiwan eine
natürliche Barriere darstellt die China
daran hindert sich im Indopazifik nach
gut dünken zu entfalten und genau aus
diesem Grund investiert China derzeit so
viel Ressourcen in seine
Marine ich meine überlegt mal wenn China
das gesamte Südchinesische Meer
einschließlich Taiwans übernehmen würde
wären die USA weniger handlungsfähig da
ihre nächsten Kampfjets mehr als 1000 km
entfernt in kinava und Guam stationiert
sind außerdem könnte China von seinen
vier luftstützpunkten im Meer aus
problemlos kampfchets auf den spreadley
und paracellineln stationieren und nicht
nur das der asiatische Riese hat ein
starkes Radarsystem auf den Inseln
aufgebaut und verfügt über eine größere
Anzahl von Raketen in der Region glaubt
ihr wirklich dass es so einfach wäre die
USA zu besiegen nun wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt ist das eher
unwahrscheinlich nicht nur weil die USA
über viel mehr Kriegserfahrung und
modernere Schiffe verfügen sondern auch
weil die viele chinesische Analysten
betonen China erst einige Probleme lösen
müsste um in einem solchen Konflikt
überhaupt erfolgreich sein zu können es
geht um Details wie Waffenlieferung der
USA an Taiwan das Fehlen eines Plans
angesichts der Sanktionen die dann
höchstwahrscheinlich verhängt werden
würden und die derzeitige Unfähigkeit
Chinas Taiwan schnell zu übernehmen doch
das ist bei Weitem nicht alles meine
Lieben Zuschauer die Analysten sagen
bereits voraus dass China seine Grenzen
des Wachstums erreicht hat und trotzdem
stellt das für Peking keinen Grund da
seine Bestrebung zu beenden das
Südchinesische Meer vollständig zu
beherrschen ganz im Gegenteil die miesen
asichten könnten sie eher noch
verstärken shei hat bereits erreicht
dass China über die größte
internationale militärische marineflotte
verfügt die Frage ist nur wann wird
China der Welt seine volle
marinefähigkeit zeigen meint ihr
wirklich wie wir schon oft behauptet
haben dass China die USA als führende
Weltmacht wirklich nicht mehr einholen
wird schreibt mir eure Einschätzung
bitte in den Kommentarbereich unter
diesem Video denn wie immer sind wir auf
eure Diskussion und eure Anregung zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und ihr vielleicht und was dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns bitte ein
Like Teil mit neuen Freunden und
diskutiert es auch mit Ihnen in diesem
Sinne macht's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald